hi I'm Greg hi
and I'm sorry tarek Instagram Twitter
snapchat - Rica - and - yes om Tariq has
never heard of honest trailers I suppose
it'd be like feeling really ill doing no
I'm excited that you haven't heard of
honest trailers okay you seen the
original buting to be at the 1991 movie
right yeah you know the cartoons people
cartoons in the basement libero
yeah to be talking fiscal is he honest
trailer version of Beauty and the Beast
okay another check the YouTube channel
it's a seal is only time a song as old
as rhyme and enchantress turning an 11
year old into a feral monster - ten
years later traffic girl in a castle
until she loved it you know that old
chestnut Beauty and the Beast welcome to
this poor provincial French village
where everyone has an American accent
it's not right for a woman to read and
we smell daughter of the local killing
machine adventures now well wrong for
adventure and she'll get just that which
he's kidnapped by the Beast a prince
who's so bad at his job he's been
missing for ten years and no one seems
to know what romance bloom between her
and Prince him they never do say his
name do they in this fairy tale that
teaches every kid it's what's on the
inside that counts but it doesn't have
to be so rich you only capsule with its
own library it's a magical age excess
violence controlling
bad-mannered here we do who imprisoned
her dad for this violence controlling
bad-mannered
fairy dude who imprisoned her dad wait
what does he woke up her dad
yes Billy wants to be left alone I'll
give you a good me just you know let him
leave and get eaten by wolves or
something that seems a lot easier than
feeding in old man for decades but bill
is it alone she's trapped with dozens of
living objects that raise dozens of
uncomfortable questions like with
everything that moves you to be a person
like are all those play people and what
happened to all the actual stuff did it
merge with a servant ha ha ha for
murdering all those villagers that
Bureau Street have crushes that guy it's
a piece of the curse white all its
servants get deform - man this movie is
messed up
so be Hindus gas at the pillars all the
Stockholm Syndrome which was the first
animated feature to be nominated for
Best Picture
blood loss - movie was a very similar
plot you will join me for Robins emotion
ah yeah ha ha and Manus - displeasure I
messed up story with some of Disney's
most beloved songs like the ancient you
know one kid sucking yourself up so it's
the work here so I love your face we all
nothing big plane we got here
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and the toxic relationships all
[Music]
the CrossFit bro haha very guy in a
little coat must loves all this French
guys on fire it's always 435 somewhere
Teesha forward and this young boy in an
old man's mouth Saved by the Bell
you have 20 brothers and sisters so yeah
you probably do huh
hey screen junkies want even born Disney
magic then be our guest and click a box
in the left on its trailer from Awana or
put the Box in the right to look in our
chanted mirror as we rank every morning
princess and find out who is the best of
the best where it'll be a guest on check
it out now no one appears in an honest
trailer by Gaston ohana means family and
family means no one gets left behind
Logan I have to be I used to be a
trailer but I became honest the Twilight
books are literally too bad oh wow
that's uh yo he like called everything
else yeah dog the screen junkies like
huge crew people I've done I've done a
couple videos on their channel but
they're like they're like a whole floor
like I'm just building a huge like a
giant staff of people like Red Bull on
production teams all of what shopping
yeah yeah just leaves Toria headed yeah
need to be funded yeah I thought that
was really well done bien well I love
the honest shows when they're not just
being nitpicky when they're pointing out
suffered her like that's pretty true
actually yeah like okay routing the beef
is a rather abusive story kidnapping
people that's alright like she has range
fists scary ever and he looks like [ __ ]
within this hot-ass Belle's us to be
like you know I'm unable looks half of a
domestic
like you smoke me there's a mass all of
it
gets a pretty girl is what this listen I
just have we've seen many women get into
an unhealthy toxic really haha because
they go every once in a while he's night
and that's what and that's when we see
the real him that's that's when he comes
out you didn't want to be tough hard on
yeah that's a classic genius or yeah it
is a classic Gazoo story I feel like
every great Rampal has to unhealthy
people coming together I really like how
they said like Sam so is the first
animated movie to be nominated for Best
Picture they show that my clothes like
that must've been just a weird turn on I
like is crazy cannibalistic stuff right
but this goes back to how the officers
don't make sense to me yeah alright
they should be genre categories can't
just go what's a better movie Beauty and
the Beast or sound to the look
excellently those are tube and - you
wouldn't compare those but I think it's
kind of cool dog that you could photos
like imagine that's why I'm at like
imagine if beauty in the desert is be
known I'd be like oh yeah it was cartoon
it was awesome that's true I that is
true I don't know if anime movies ever
won again I mean yeah I really present
the team though I'm lying in are you
doing the songs within like parody
version because it's kind of like a bad
lip reading where you know because it's
animated you don't you're not going to
be so distracted to the point where
you're like it doesn't look like they're
saying those words it's they form the
mouths move enough to the point where
they can put their own words and there's
only one syllable formation yeah exactly
whatever you want to make iced tea or
something like that as long as I can
just follow the same format of the
lyrics and materials beat it works
perfectly yeah that was a really well
done video yeah when they were talking
about that I like to keep these like
little things used to be old people like
yeah I really puts things in perspective
like your slavery just blatantly havin a
lotta flavor hey that is evil and
playing Viva
that look like teacups and gambling's up
and yeah we're okay with it like not
only to talk funny
this video points out really well how
the bees did a lot of like rather
abusive things and then all the Menem
felt like her abusive and yet she she
faltered this guy over time and I think
that's I guess if ever mainland man's
gotta be the money doesn't matter if it
could be outside but if you have a bunch
of slaves in a huge book collection yeah
how the man is a giant freaking mesh
that is on ballroom library and I got
her point out how if I thought about
that too
how he's like the prince but you know
ones notice is that you got idiot is not
watching over the town anyway it's not
like a thing you should be looking at
another prince or a king or it's like
yeah I love their likes when they
question the rules of the universe with
how you know that all these people turn
into like kitchen silverware but what
happens to the actual silverware right
yeah where is the actual like exactly
pointed out the Murrays or something
like and with the toy and the idea of
the toilet
Oh sock if you got stuck at the toilet
totally terrible swishy is beat using as
well you can say life could be [ __ ]
didn't sound effect where you go yeah
honey for the cricket everyone re heard
them at how would I do that was great
absolute hell I'm glad I can introduce
you to honest trailer yeah definitely
have to check your stuff off yeah man
alright guys will subscribe to screen
junkies drive you the real rejects click
a notification Bell yeah do that
and last but not least don't desperately
follow hard on Instagram and Twitter and
snapchat at Sarika 2-1 to do it it's not
that bird about it he's not like me when
I'm around Jewish black girls which is
rare
wait let me have to think about them I
wish black girls very Dutch I'm like
you're such a rare breed around
California I got it
have you
but I never get laid with the Jewish
black girl very depressing right now do
you think I feel like black girl like me
I know I can't really speak for all of
that girls I can speak for the girls
that it attracted to me because I know
what's they're attracted to me back at
zero lager
I haven't gotten hit up by a few black
girls really you have yeah like
subscribers guys literally right I just
think I'm really cute that's awesome
she doesn't follow a 5-year follow-up I
acted sleeping my subscribers yeah that
give me a serious sleeping with my
subscribe log all of it
oh yeah yeah you still need your
reactions having sex with all that you
said you can do your reaction to me -
we're going on longer than I just keep
going you know this is the outro